put that black pawn on the a file next
move for example if black goes and gets
greedy and takes one of the white pawns
with his rook and white's rook is just
going to step back and gobble up that
black a pawn and this one might be
heading towards a draw in the next few
moves looks like great defense by magnus
carlsen yeah but but now we can sort of
see that yan's uh move which i don't
think any of us
were going to play taking on c6 to the
pawn it worked out incredibly well
because if anyone had chances after that
it was actually yan
magnus had to find that quite tough
defensive move uh which she did he did
obviously find and well okay black is a
pawn up here but white's so active not
even a porno no no it's not okay right
yeah yeah
we're racing towards the draw now we're
about to see it any second we're just
going to see checks the position's about
to repeat itself the first game of the
final ends in a draw wow magnus carlsen
with the white pieces it is a draw this
first game in
the first match in the final magnus
logging off yana pognacci shaking